[Musique]
planté en pleine campagne cette
cathédrale de verre et la seule serre de
production de tomates hors sol de l'awb
sa dimension est impressionnante 6000
mètres carrés de surface sa production
annuelle est de quelques 300 tonnes de
tomates pour la faire tourner sept
employés et paul les deux gérants et
comme vous allez le voir la culture
réclament des soins incessants et des
installations à gérer au quotidien
on est loin de soupçonner olivier roy et
le gérant de cette exploitation
il nous emmène découvrir le coeur de la
serre qui singulièrement se trouve à
l'extérieur
il s'agit de la chaufferie là où tout
commence
c'est le dernier gros investissements
qu'il a effectuée passé à la biomasse
afin de rester cohérent avec son projet
ça sent les chaudières bois donc qui
tourne avec des bois issus de deux
fournisseurs locaux
l'objectif c'est toujours de rester dans
le même le même esprit que la culture
sans pesticides
c'est toujours dans le respect respect
de l'environnement c'est quand même des
chaudières qui font toutes les deux
c'est 100 kilowatts
donc c'est en
en plein hiver c'est ça peut monter
jusqu'à 20 à 30 mètres cubes par jour de
bois les chaudières ne chauffe pas là
c'est la chauffe le ballon de stockage
qui lui chauffe la serre ce qui fait que
ponctuellement par les gros besoins de
puissance sur la serre qui sont absorbés
par le ballon l'investissement de
l'ensemble de leurs de 500000 euros
heureusement il ya des subventions qui
permettent de faire que ce soit faisable
sinon ce serait pas réalisable le prix
serait le coût serait trop important sur
100 le sent léser ses principes ça c'est
l'ademe qui fait les financements donc
on est un dossier a été monté pour la
chambre d'agriculture
il a fait un gros travail que nous
permettent d'avoir les subventions de
l'ademe bien chauffé la serre est
primordial pour un développement
harmonieux des cultures tout est donc
géré par ordinateur au plus près des
variations des nombreux paramètres pris
en cours ça nous permet de chauffer
mieux donc mieux répondre aux besoins de
mou dans la culture et donc on a préféré
produire on a gagné un peu con semaines
de rentrer en production en s'offrant un
petit peu mieux
donc c'est quand même intéressant et
après le chauffant mieux on arrive aussi
à mieux gérer les maladies
donc du coup avoir des planques plus
saines et le sait comment pareil comme
on travaille sur une la gestion
climatique pour lutter contre les
maladies et pas contredit en n'utilisant
pas de produits chimiques
c'est un gérant crima qu'on arrive à
lutter contre les maladies
donc c'est important pour nous aussi
bien sur la bonne température est loin
d'être suffisante pour espérer une bonne
récolte
nous verrons demain la réalité de la
culture hors sol
[Musique]